surprise bonus thursday video on my
channel feel both offended and excited
this is a bonus video this week for two
reasons one I had purchased this family
fun makeup kit thinking that I was going
to do some sort of funny hilarious uh
Halloween makeup tutorial type of thing
and instead I made a video about how to
be a Disney Princess daughter but right
after I shot that video I was seeing all
of these makeup tutorials about how to
make yourself into an emoji and I
realized no one was making themselves
into my favorite emoji which is this I
mean one I I want to give him space it's
the old man emoji and so I thought today
I would try to make myself into the old
man emoji some of you will probably want
to be this for Halloween because it's
gonna be great know how can you live up
to it how can you live up to that why am
I even trying this and the second reason
that I am doing this video is because I
am part of the ad councils new campaign
I am a witness and anti-bullying
campaign which I am really excited that
they even asked me to be a part of the
Iowa Witness campaign is launching today
October 22nd talking about bullying
sucks because I think we've all been
bullied I think talking about bullying
is a great way to kind of take the power
out of the bullying you know the more
you say one word over and over again the
less meaning it has in your brain and
with that the Ad Council has created an
anti-bullying campaign centered around
an emoji not the old man emoji I know I
know
but that would be a weird message and
wouldn't be direct and we take a lot of
explanation
instead they chose one and the purpose
of the eye emoji is to use it when you
are witness to some
thing I am a witness send it to the
bully or to the bullied through a text
message or through social media however
it makes sense to you to just let them
know that you see what's happening I
will put all the links in the
description box below that you would
need if you were interested in this
campaign and I hope you are because I am
and use the I to let people know that
you are witness or really this old man
emoji face Halloween tutorial and then
just sidle up to the bullies when they
least expect it maybe in a dark alley
when they're all alone and maybe like in
the rooms when they're sleeping and just
wake them up a little bit and then say
no one will believe you that this is
happening
stop being awful to everyone else and
this will stop if that seems like a lot
to do maybe just download the keyboard
so before we officially begin we're
gonna brush out our dirty gross hair
into a ponytail so that we could
foreseeably put it under a bald cap but
we don't have a bald cap so we can just
put it in a ponytail and pretend if you
can get your hands on a bald cap
Congrats stop bragging but we couldn't
so I'm going to use a nude tank top
instead I'm going to place it over my
hairline like a bald cap be impressed
with how great it looks for a second
then go back to being terrified that I'm
actually putting a tutorial on my
channel I'm going to tie it in the back
and may find that it looks terrible in
the back because you only see me from
the front if you go out in the real
world you might want to fix the back
then I'm going to poorly handle some
foundation and try to blend that into my
face to blend my fake bald cap into my
fake facial coloring which I don't know
that any of this is actually helping I
think I just wanted to pretend I was
like a beauty guru for a second doing
something with coloring I think I might
be color blind I then tried to use
concealer to blend in my eyebrows and
quickly realize that concealer does not
blend in your eyebrows so watch other
beauty gurus to figure out how to blend
in your eyebrows then I got to use my
makeup kit that I bought after I turned
it right side up and I tried to use some
of the colors in there to blend in
eyebrows and quickly learn I just don't
know how to do it maybe watch someone
like candy Johnson so then I moved on to
pouring old Tommy dust all over my face
aka setting my foundation with
translucent powder from there I moved on
to bronzing my face because when you
look at this emoji the entire outline of
his face is very tan and contoured this
man is retired and living in he is not
alive which is important to recognize
after this I messed her off with my
lighting setup a bunch like I knew what
I was doing and continued to contour my
face like I was a beauty guru on an
actual mission rather than a solo Lois
and Clark
just trying to get by then I took an
eyebrow pencil and decided to draw the
three prominent wrinkles on the old man
emoji forehead and took a look at myself
and realized this is actually working
out absolutely nothing can go wrong from
here and then grab the black pencil from
the Halloween makeup kit to draw the
oversized smiley mouth and realized I
hated it so I used instead the black
face paint from the Halloween makeup kit
and realized oh my god so I just
submitted to my own terribleness and
drew the two shaded lines that come down
from the old van emojis now then I went
through a very long series of trials and
tribulations
well tribulations and tribulations of
trying to make larger cartoonish emoji
eyes using white face makeup and black
eye shadow black eyeliner before
ultimately realizing I'm not capable of
this so again watch candy Johnson I took
all the terrible tries off my eyes and
went with just some plain foundation
covered eyes with some black eyeliner in
the corner try make the eyes pop then I
moved on to making the gray Tufts of
hair that the emoji has I took some
cardboard and cut it into two half
circles and covered it in duct tape to
get the gray color and duct
taped it to the side of my head in a
very crude alien elderly Minnie Mouse
like fashion I went back through and
tried to fix the mouth with some liquid
eyeliner and there you go the creepy so
it wasn't supposed to be creepy but it
is definitely creepy old man emoji
Halloween costume
I hope on some level this made you want
to download the I'm a witness keyboard
for egg councils I am a witness
anti-bullying campaign I don't know